ich versuche mich von nichts zu einem
Porsche hoch zu handeln mit dreifacher
Verstärkung und auch dreifacher
Motivation ging es wieder zurück auf den
Golfplatz und in den See
boah meine stinkt so
am Anfang lief noch richtig gut genauso
wie beim letzten Mal es waren unheimlich
viele Bälle drin doch mit der Zeit
wurden die Hände immer leerer aber kein
Grund zur Sorge es gibt noch einen
zweiten sie auf dem Golfplatz zweiter
Teich komplett voll mit meinem Auto
komplett voll mit Golfbällen ging es
zurück nach Köln um die Bälle zu
sortieren sauber zu machen und zu
verkaufen Schätze jetzt mal in den
Kommentaren wie viele Bälle wir
tatsächlich aus dem Wasser holen konnten
und ich sag schon so viel es sind eine
Menge für das Waschen Trick 17 wir sind
im Waschsalon Gefahren acht
Waschmaschine gebucht und für eine halbe
Stunde schleudern lassen guckt euch das
an das komplette Geisteskranken frisch
glänzen Bella habe ich dann in Paket und
durch ganz Deutschland geschickt wie
viel Kohle dabei rumkam und noch vieles
mehr erfahrt ihr in meinem Youtube Video
seid euch aber sicher das war erst der
Anfang